emitir un voto es solo el comienzo de lo
que es un largo y sinuoso camino desde
el 3 de noviembre hasta la investidura
del 20 de enero porque en eeuu elegir un
presidente es un proceso nacional y
federal pero las reglas son diferentes
estado por estado cómo funciona el
proceso primero están las cuentas
provisionales es decir cuando en los
estados se les dio el triunfo a dubai de
donald trump por ejemplo luego se
comprueban los números finales de los
condados con precisión es entonces
cuando los firman los funcionarios
estatales o los representantes
electorales los gobernadores también
pueden dar su sello de aprobación
entonces los delegados del colegio
electoral del estado pueden reunirse y
votar yo ya certificó sus resultados el
viernes los condados de pensilvania
tienen hasta este lunes se espera que
michigan certifique también hoy luego el
martes se espera que nevada minnesota y
carolina del norte den sus sellos de
aprobación seguidos por arizona y
wisconsin hay varios plazos pero hay un
límite
los 50 estados saben que el 8 de
diciembre es una fecha clave para todos
denominada el plazo de puerto seguro
deben entregar los conteos certificados
por tarde ese día si no quieren que el
congreso se involucre antes de la
reunión del colegio electoral el 14 de
diciembre con sus demandas sus
invitaciones a los legisladores de
michigan a washington y su exigencia de
un recuento en gioia donald trump es
visto por muchos como intentando de
descarrilar o retrasar lo que suele ser
una formalidad con la idea de que si los
resultados no se certifican entonces las
legislaturas estatales en las que los
republicanos son mayoría podrían elegir
partidarios de trump al colegio
electoral una anulación del voto popular
que es poco probable porque sería
impugnada en los tribunales y no
cambiaría el liderazgo de joe biden en
ese organismo